hi my name is Pedro Fonseca I work on
the water treatment business but i'm
here to present you prototyping
interface tools for data exploration in
Virtual Reality environments my
presentation is already downloadable and
although there is an abstract to this
presentation I hope my at my
introduction kind of sets the mood this
is outside not so scientific turn
presentation the main motivation for
doing it is to try to find an excuse to
get a virtual reality headset through
our series work that we do every day on
Mathematica a little bit as we did for
the rest berry pie yes like it gave us
an excuse to to start using one so well
some basics about the topic well we know
that we have information coming for from
a lot of sources that can be visualized
in 3d this information can be actually
40 that is it belongs to one point in
space and it has one specific value it
can easily even have a value that is
actually a vector and so it can be of 5d
and it can have many other dimensions it
can be transient in time it can be from
a real world or it can be from a
computation like computational fluid
dynamics and other type of calculation
system well to see this information we
typically rely on plots but well
headsets are becoming more and more
interesting for everyone yes not just
for the for the for the games and so
there are a lot of interesting
alternatives to see this kind of
information from within the information
itself now we have here are some
examples of very cheap systems to a
little bit more expensive to extremely
expensive
yes and of course I'm sure that everyone
remembers probably the most expensive of
them all yes let's hope we get there
someday and we know that this is
becoming extremely popular to talk about
this topic and so I thought well why not
introduce it into the world of
Mathematica because in the last year's
conference I don't think there was a
talk on the subject this year we already
see a lot of stuff on it we have a hose
reef downstairs so that we see that the
interest is starting to get there but
well does it is it enough for me to
justify buying a virtual reality headset
let's see well in both from language
there are actually functions that are
very well tailored for presenting ville
metric information on on the screen why
am I talking about Phil metric
information well because typically we
see on the media talking about 2d shapes
in a 3d well and that is kind of the
most common and so I thought well I have
to talk about something different yes
something a little bit more rare so
these are the typical function that we
can use on Mathematica to visualize
ville metric information and we also
have a bunch of functions that allows us
to really visualize this kind of
information but after has having been
transforming to kind of 2d information
yes well again and although repeating
myself this is just for the fan and so
let's see if we can get somewhere where
we could say yeah I would like to have a
headset ok so um this is what you
typically see on virtual reality
environment so polygons here we already
see a limitation of Mathematica so we
are inside the
Space Shuttle example data and I can
even see the controls in size or two
satellite inside and so there's missing
information to really take it seriously
us because it's empty it's an empty
example okay but there are is there is
much more serious examples in in in the
example data okay it's it's a little bit
slow to turn these kind of images around
yes this one runs pretty fast but well
there is much faster we can do much
faster with with volumetric rendering on
the CUDA and we all know that well this
kind of these information is getting
more and more common for instance
there's a project of some people trying
to scan in 3d all the fishes species in
the world I think it's a extreme
interest for all of us in this room of
course it might be of extreme
interesting for many people like a
storage scopic view well that is
probably the most easy thing to deal
with that is to create the two images
for the two eyes there's a bunch of
functions available the community has
put it out some demonstration projects
about it and and and I think they give a
pretty good idea of what can be done I'm
actually using I think the code of this
one for for a small example of what can
be done let me see there there are
things that are quite heavy okay so the
first obstacle that we have is that we
have to sit through and so in Wolfram
language is quite easy we we have
opacity functions that allows us to
let's say vanish some of the data that's
great now if we put this together with
the things that we are seeing on on on
the previous slide well we can imagine
navigating ourselves on
real stereoscopic view now this is a
yeah that's that's correct so this is a
cross I this is a cross I projection and
so you'll have to put your finger in
front of your nose and trying to see it
in 3d it is actually not extremely
difficult to do but but you can see that
it is slow so it is when we navigate
well it's it's kind of yeah it's not
really ready for for virtual reality
outside it can be made much faster
unfortunately could Ville metric render
has some problems in v 11 they are
already listed on on on the Balkans beg
list and so that that should be fine and
well we have to we need a way to control
the way that what we see as information
so coming back to our fish I find the
image extremely interesting evolved from
a bottom language Mathematica interface
has has this kind of a system that is
called color function editor it's
actually I don't think it's a good name
because it's actually an opacity editor
and the color function picker because we
can actually pick the color but we can
not really manipulate the color or added
color so what you can manipulate its the
transparency in itself so let's try to
to do an examples here now a color
editor would look more like what is here
than by kevin daly from well posted on
the community and actually this topic
about opacity calibration of passage
color editing etc it's extremely
important because we'll be inside these
information so it has to be extremely
fine tuned for us to see anything and so
I think that what it is missing is some
kind of opacity and color editor on the
same interface now I have copied here an
image from another software that I think
presents a good an example of what we
should probably have these this capacity
of specifying
an opacity and a color function for this
kind of information is available on one
on Mathematica and fortunately they are
both linked to the same data field that
is we cannot have an opacity function
acting on one field and a color function
acting on another field it's actually
the fourth dimension that they are
looking at and so it restricts a lot on
the things that we can do there are many
more details that I found here like the
fact that image 3d uses just one color
function for everything and the density
plot 3d actually devises it into opacity
function and color function well there
are different things that we can see
there's also another limitation that not
we will encounter when trying to
simulate a virtual reality environment
inside of our head is that once we join
two images that are let's say two
graphics that have different colors
functions when we show them together
actually when pics dip the color
function of the other so we cannot join
together to images of different color
functions and that is kind of battering
because it of it difficult tells us to
do things like this for instance let's
try to navigate to the inside of this
engine so again it's a little bit slow
but but we can get there imagine that
you have your your aquas rift or vive or
whatever and that you are trying to get
to that sphere so we have to go slow
because this is kind of herbs we went a
little bit too too fast and now let's
imagine that to explore this environment
I would like to make a hole like an
x-ray around these spheres yes so I can
actually make the hole yes not exactly
as I would lie because it's not possible
to specify opacity for a given position
I can specify opacity for a field for
the for the fourth dimension field but I
cannot specify for a given voxel and
that is the kind of battering for
constructing interfaces too many
light or to explore this kind of
information so for instance I can also
specify an x-ray vision a kind of x-ray
vision of course it's different way of
seeing it it's actually a high range
specification but I cannot put both
together and that's that's that's limits
a lot of how we could explore this kind
of information like creating a hole in
the wall and and things like that okay
so there's a brief summary of the
limitations that I find on these seen
through that that mathematical ouses one
of the things is that and I cannot I
cannot specify opacity and color by
position it's only linked at the at the
field itself and I cannot join to do to
specify two different images with
specifications different together okay
now when I think on tools we can think
of things like a flashlight a spotlight
duck traits invisibility fields as some
kind of burn utility that dances
information on a specific area now let's
let's try to do this laughs so let's
let's try to to go inside the motor in
again and try to to deploy one of these
one of these these let's say
invisibility flashlights yes let's
suppose that I see a hold areas and
let's try to move this flash light
around okay so this might be interesting
to have as a tool there so we are
prototype prototyping tools to have with
us when we have the casket on so what
what that the helmet on sorry what could
we think of tools for these well this
one like a flashlight could be
interesting that would just just do
matter disappear yes let's put ourselves
in the center to try to understand what
it could be it could be like a laser
beam yes with an era that just makes
things disappear
okay so that's that's that could be a
nice thing to have now this is
conceptually wrong because well when I
think of a flashlight we think of the
cone yes because that's how it the light
is generated on a simple flashlight and
that means that we would be peeking
through it through a hole yes that's
like that the colonies in should be
inverted it's a because if we try to do
matter disappear but we just see through
the cone it's a little bit strange yes
let's like picking through it through
for a small hole yeah so probably well
we have to change this tool to something
like that an inverse cone with an area
around us that has disappeared so that
we can see a little bit further away
than just a few centimeters from our
eyes and so this is probably what we are
looking for now that guy there has
copyrights okay that that's actually me
scanned on 2015 conference and and we
could also think on on on having a
bathing field from the person app to the
limits of this invisibility field yes
and so that would be like and not make
it totally disappear but make it a
little bit brighter that area so that we
can see a little bit further away than
just where we are here there are some
currently odds things going on when we
try to do this with Mathematica that
obviously was not thought from the
beginning to have to be applied on
empirical reality environments now we
have to think that when we use these
flashlights and and all these
parameterize ation of of opacity
functions and things like that we are we
have that the helmet on and so how do we
actually do it yes to do we take the
helmet off and go to mathematic and put
the helmet on again well of course we
would like to have these that is
manipulate with appearance Minority
Report I don't know if Wolfram research
has that on their priorities probably
not right now
but I think that that's more or less
what we would like to have now it's
interesting to see that we can prototype
these kind of things in Mathematica
better than I would have guessed for for
instance there's me again with with the
helmet on and and I can project next to
me manipulation interface and again
actually I'm going to try to it's very
small but probably I it's actually
possible to pick it up and to manipulate
the function it's it's difficult but
it's actually let their there it is yes
so the tools are there to implement
infected manipulation interfaces on our
helmet and that might be interesting for
for for for the future but what do we
exactly want to have next to us well a
lot of things here we see for instance
the color manipulation function that I
presented before we can we may want to
deploy slices of control plots and
things like that and so we might want to
manage them make them disappear create
new ones and things like that and so yes
we need kind of an interface to walk
with us to explore this kind of
information and then there's the space
Mouse because everything that is in the
reach of our hands that's great but do
we really have to walk the field up to a
certain area of information in order to
highlight it make it disappear create a
slice there well obviously we need kind
of a point or yes there are a lot of
these things being imagine at this right
moment by a lot of people these are the
things that come with well that can be
bought as extras for the aquas rift and
for the wife and so we already saw that
that concept on the previous image where
we just had the blue light line the blue
line pointing as a laser yes and well I
think this is it can kind of childish
image but I think it gives more or less
than idea that is we are inside the
field and we point it and we make things
disappear but well in in in
typical view / reality environment well
there's also audio that took you lose
nowadays yes because Mathematica now has
audio and say we could control these
systems a little bit with audio but in a
typical virtual reality environment well
when you point a laser it hits a surface
because typical Virtual Reality
environments are made of 2d shapes in 3d
walls and so it's kind of clear where
the laser hits on vil metric information
we are just pointing a laser to a cloud
and so what does it exactly mean how can
i pick a cloud how come how can i define
where my laser ends yes and so we could
think of different ways of doing like
intensity degradation laser a
manipulation of a sphere in through a
distance things like that well let's
let's try to see what we could do a of
these kind of things so let's imagine
that we are inside these these
information this is actually function
it's not really not a scan from real
life and that we try to put a lot of
things together on easy image and so we
are fixing in a position as a given
position and we have our special laser
yes an hour special laser has these
spheres attached to it that are
positioned on high and low points of a
given field yes and when I try to move
that laser now i'm going to move with
manipulate but that would be me moving
those kind of plastic accessories that
come with that without the the virtual
reality headsets you see is you see that
yeah it's a little bit sluggish that
will get there you see that the spheres
move to to to the new high and low
points and one thing that we could have
next to assets the actually graphic of
the field being traversed and so in this
way I can actually pinpoint specific
locations in in space even if my laser
just goes through infinity as and for
instance let's this thing is kind of
hitting what sins and
what is a bit fuzzy after it and so
let's try to make it disappear well once
one thing that I can easily see is that
well it is a high point yes and so I can
probably pick that point and okay my
green seer became red that's that's kind
of easy and now I could for instance
deploy a segmentation of of this space
yes and so I'm pointing to a thing that
is not near me and I'm actually able to
pick a specific point in space of this
volumetric data without displacing
myself to that point of course i can
pick another one let's try to pick
another one for instance yeah now we
have to raise a little bit yeah good
enough yes we are rare pointing to it
yeah we are pointing to it so net let's
let's try to choose that one so that one
is was was much further away and I still
can choose it and well I can actually
for instance well I'm going to hide the
segmentation so I have chosen a specific
spot and let's try to hide that amount
of information so that i can see through
as as a way of exploring this
information it's a little bit slow
because unfortunately we cannot
manipulate opacity of locations so I'm
actually manipulating the entire data
field that is I'm making the all those
pills become 0 so that they just vanish
within our opacity function but but I
think it can give an idea of the type of
interface is that we could develop and
there it goes so we just made that piece
of information disappear with a new tool
that we develop that is a laser that has
high and low points okay so
it might be an interesting tool to have
and one thing that that might also be
interesting is to try to have that data
focus interfaces that is we we have a
lot of data to treat here we have 4g dot
but we might have information of 56 d
and we are traveling through this
information and sometimes we have to
pick based on on fields that are not
very hot site easy to to individualize
and and one way is to try to reduce the
dimension of the data to something that
can be like Plata belen Judy and in 2d
you can more easily choose with some
kind of window or polygon or something
like that let's try to use an example
from the documentation for instance the
documentation has these this example
here and as a dimension reduction we can
reduce these information these 3d
information into 2d and actually we can
manipulate that data [ __ ] you see window
that that will actually select specific
points that are within the criteria of
this dimension reduction and and we
could imagine having this window next to
us so that we could make things
disappear based for instance on
temperature while we are inside a field
of density something like that yes and
and did this is actually demonstrated
here on the next slide if it moves up so
this is actually exactly the same thing
and I can actually manipulate the window
but well as you can see that it is
extremely small but it proves that
mathematical can actually represent this
kind of adventure so I'm going to try to
manipulate this window yeah it is it is
okay very difficult but probably the red
dots will change and there they change
so it
actually possible to manipulate the
window on the virtual reality
environment developed entirely on
Mathematica so this is this is
interesting well now trying to push to
our topic that was volumetric
information we can do exactly the same
thing this is also an example from the
documentation and we can also indeed
relies a specific specific points in
space based on their value and based on
a dimension reduction in this case the
dimensional reduction is we reduce the
for the information into that does the
set locations that coordinate and the
field value yes and so when I reduce in
this direction i'm actually just
speaking high points on the image in the
in terms of their locations if i reduce
i'm picking the entire area and this i'm
just picking the bottom the bottom
information i can actually add contours
but well that's the easy part that is
that's having to the information into
the free real world and so and it will
probably do it and there it is yes and
and so to finish to finish all i hope
you have enjoyed first it is this again
it is just to see to what point we could
push Mathematica to do this kind of odd
of visualization well it might it could
be thanked fan to have this kind of
things in the future yes like to have
pre-prepared Virtual Reality
environments to explore specific
specific function specific fields things
like that yeah so I hope it motivates
someone to to explore that area and so
can I use Mathematica as an excuse I
mean for the acquisition of a virtual
reality headset well I don't think that
we can use it as an excuse for for for a
500 euros equipment
but probably for the cardboard yeah
probably it's it's already enough yes so
thank you very much
[Applause]